i'm jason chaffetz i'm katie pavlich i'm
steve ducey and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday december 9th 2020 i'm lisa
brady
battle lines in washington over
president trump's ongoing claims
of a rigged election this is far and
away
the worst example of voter fraud and
election
theft it's a wild conspiracy to think
that democrats
and republicans in these five or six key
states
would rig an election i'm dave anthony
the corona virus surge has led to
renewed restrictions across the country
but more businesses are not complying
this time
so closing down was not an option for us
because we would
not have been able to reopen and i'm
abby hornacek
i've got the final word on the fox news
[Music]
rundown
joe biden is trying to move on tapping
more members of an incoming
administration
and formally introducing his health team
on tuesday there's a team of world-class
experts at the top of their fields
crisis tested
defined by a deep sense of duty honor
and patriotism while biden was holding
that event in delaware president trump
was holding a white house summit on his
administration's covet vaccine program
saying we're on the verge of a medical
miracle ahead of an fda advisory
committee hearing on thursday
he also took questions from reporters
and didn't budge from his claims of
widespread
election fraud let's see whether or not
somebody has the courage
whether it's a legislator or
legislatures
or whether it's a justice of the supreme
court or a number of justices of the
supreme court
let's see if they have the courage to do
what everybody in this country knows
is right but just a few hours later the
u.s supreme court rejected an effort to
reverse biden's win in pennsylvania
over questions about the state's
certification process and whether the
state's mail-in voting law was
constitutional
pennsylvania congressman mike kelly and
other plaintiffs arguing
there should have been a constitutional
amendment to authorize it
the state's highest court said they
waited too long to challenge it
the u.s supreme court turning the case
aside without comment
regardless of ongoing challenges in
court tuesday was the deadline for
states to certify their election results
in time to ensure their electors will be
counted
in the electoral college vote which is
fast approaching on monday
but one supporter of the president in
congress is looking ahead to january
when congress counts those votes and
formally declares the winner
you know we have a choice we can either
fight
for fair honest and accurate elections
or we can surrender alabama republican
congressman mo brooks
plans to challenge slates of electors in
contested states
though he needs a senate republican to
join him and he's already acknowledged
it's an uphill climb
it does not make any difference what the
odds are of success
the question is do you surrender do you
duck in your foxhole
and wait until the fighting is over with
or do you stand tall
and fight for the republic of the united
states of america
and what underpins it which is our
election system
so i don't really know how to evaluate
the odds of whether we're going to win
or lose except i do know this
if you surrender you're guaranteed to
lose if you fight you have a chance to
win
what about the safe harbor deadline
that came and went on tuesday um
essentially preventing a change in
electors chosen according to state law
after that point is it not too late for
this
no absolutely not that has zero effect
on the role the united states congress
bear in mind that in the united states
constitution
article one article two in the twelfth
amendment congress
has the absolute unbridled control
over all election contest involving
federal elected officials that means we
had the final say even over the supreme
court
over the election of house members over
the election of senators and over the
election
of presidents of the united states when
those elections
are contested now you can't actually
go it alone though you've got to have
some some support in the senate
as well how is that taking shape have
you had any momentum
on that front i have met with a number
of senators
they are pondering the situation i'm not
going to identify
the names of the senators i've met with
and i'm not going to disclose where they
might end up being
because in my judgment is really up to
them
to do their homework as i have done
do their research as i have done and
reach the conclusion i have reached
which is that this is far
and away the worst example of voter
fraud
and election theft in the united states
of america's history
it involves the presidency of the united
states and my judgment
if based on the evidence i have seen
which i find compelling
and overwhelming if we limited
the election count to the votes cast
by eligible american citizens
lawfully then donald trump easily won
the electoral college and donald trump
is due to be
re-elected president united states there
have been
calls to make the process more uniform
and streamlined around the country i
mean
is that something you think republicans
would support those kinds of changes
people who believe in our republic who
want an honest and accurate voting
system
support that but socialist democrats do
not
because that makes it harder for them to
steal elections
it's just that cut and dried okay uh who
is it
that made it easier for illegal aliens
to vote well the democrats did when they
jammed through the united states
congress in 1993
voter registration act legislation that
makes it illegal for our voter
registrars to require proof of
citizenship
when illegal aliens and other nine
citizens come in to vote
who is it that has made it harder to
prove that someone who comes in is
actually the voter they say they are
was democrats who is it that came up
with and
forced it this vote by mail scheme
throughout the united states of america
that both jimmy carter and james baker
in their report in two thousand five in
this federal election commission
uh type entity uh you know they
condemned
absentee ballot voting and in
mass mailing of ballot voting and who is
it that pushed this
weakened scheme well the socialist
democrats did
what about the simmering debate about
abolishing
the electoral college system is this
just going to keep
gaining traction in either party
depending on who wins an election
i am absolutely opposed to abolishing
the electoral college system and here's
why a little bit of history is in order
the electoral college system was
critical to the creation of the united
states of america as a country
we would not be a country but for the
electoral college system
and that's because the smaller states
would not join
what became the united states of america
keep in mind that they were independent
countries at the time
in 1776 through 1789 and it there are 13
colonies or 13 independent countries and
the electoral college was submitted as a
compromise to the smaller states that
they still would have some voice
in the governance of the united states
of america i believe
that is still the case i do not want
the united states of america beholding
to the block votes
from left-wing socialist states such as
california or new york or just go down
the list
and so the electoral college is serving
its purpose
one in the creation of the united states
of america because we would not
exist without it and two to give those
lightly
populated states some voice of substance
in the election of the president united
states not every democrat
supports doing away with the electoral
college or
thinks it's worth the time and effort to
try i got that question a lot during the
presidential and
my comment was look that's so far out of
the realm of possibility
ohio congressman and former presidential
hopeful tim ryan
you're talking about a constitutional
amendment
um and and so
you know to me it never made a whole lot
of sense we've got
we've got to figure out how to go in
this small states in the rural areas and
learn how to win
uh and and not you know uh you know
not that there's not legitimate issues
but
we're looking to pass budgets and keep
the government open
you know it is a bare minimum i just
don't think that
we have the the time or energy to really
put behind something
that would be so so out of reach so it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense to me
how much of a chance do you think
congressman mo brooks has
with his plan to challenge the slates of
electors
on the house floor in january
oh i think it's a zero percent chance uh
you know it's it's to me it's a you know
a lot of grandstanding and you know
trying to
raise money you know online on social
media by doing
things like this and i just you know i i
just
it's going at the heart of the
constitutional process that has been set
up and
this country has been has been
participating in for
you know over 200 and some years so
i i really don't think it's going to go
anywhere if everything were the opposite
just imagine for a minute and you really
thought the election had been stolen
would you be willing to do the same
thing that he's doing right now
no i mean you you where's the proof i
mean
every court including courts with
trump appointed conservative republicans
are shaming these attorneys for
for having zero proof and the attorneys
are saying
fraud on the outside of the courthouse
but when the
rule 11 and these other requirements for
lawyers to have to tell the truth in the
court apply
they say there isn't any fraud so i mean
we
you can see what's going on here why
don't they say the same thing
in the courtroom that they say outside
of the courtroom and these are the
president's attorneys
because they're the facts just aren't
there and so you have no proof
in any of these states it's a wild
conspiracy to think that democrats
and republicans and these five or six
key states
would rig an election that would
put a democrat on top of
president trump but then we lost
congressional seats in those same states
so you know it's like it wasn't a
democratic title wave
you know we didn't do well in the senate
races we didn't do well in the house
races
uh so you know there's a lot going on
here but to say that there's this vast
conspiracy between democrats and
republicans
and local boards of elections all over
the united states
is a pretty big stretch what do you
think is the
possible way forward here to help along
those lines with
with public trust and the integrity of
the system i mean
there have been some calls to make the
voting process more uniform
and streamlined around the country is
there
something like that that might work you
know we'd always like to see more people
voting and less lines and i think
there's a way to to make this happen
more efficiently but that would mean
maybe federal money going down to the
locals and having them
implement you know the changes that they
need or improving the staffing or
whatever the case may
be i would like to see some of these
states change their laws
to count those ballots first that come
in
through mail not wait until election day
to count them which is
what led to the decision
coming in days later as opposed to
having all those votes counted
before election day and maybe that's a
staffing issue or something i'm not sure
but those state laws should be changed
and
those votes should be counted before
election day so we have results
on the night of election day if at all
possible well it looks like we're
we're heading into the home stretch so
to speak um
are you how do you feel about the pics
that the president-elect has made and
um you know the ability of the incoming
administration to sort of
get its agenda done given the current
climate in washington
i hope so i mean i hope you regardless
of what happens in georgia that we can
find
some issues out there that are
down the middle that mitch mcconnell can
agree on i think there's a lot of
opportunity around
the new energy economy uh including
natural gas
uh in in moving and trying to
you know dominate these these energy
industries and not let china beat us
at all of these um you know have a very
disciplined
approach to to how we do this um
you know making sure that that uh you
know we're
uh rewarding people for their their hard
work
uh you know around around these economic
issues there's a ton
of opportunity for us to be able to do
that
ohio congressman tim ryan thank you very
much for your time
thanks for having me
this is abby hornacek with your fox news
commentary coming up
is this the beginning of the end of the
pandemic
coronavirus vaccinations have started in
britain
a 90 year old grandma got the very first
pfizer vaccine
shot or jab as they call it there i
thought it was a joke to tell you the
truth to start with
i couldn't believe it margaret keenan
hopes she inspires others to get
vaccinated
kind of the best for to get rid of this
terrible thing
approval in the u.s could come in days
however it could take months to stop the
coveted surge that has restrictions
reimposed nationwide but
some businesses are not complying it's
not a matter of
you know bucking the system so as you
might say but it's
it's a matter of survival brenda lunte
is refusing to stop indoor
dining at her deli in reading california
at a time when the national restaurant
association says
110 000 have closed permanently or long
term so far
that's nearly 20 percent of u.s
restaurants mike coughlin is trying to
avoid that
also defying orders in illinois still
allowing indoor dining
so closing down was not an option for us
because we would not
have been able to reopen he owns the
village tavern and grill
in carol's stream to me in into most of
people out here in the restaurant and
small business because
obviously it's not just a restaurant
that's being impacted uh
you know we had no choice but that
closed down
you know i don't have any income coming
in i i've got taxes that i do i've got
you know mortgages that are due and and
obviously payroll and
you know any costs that you haven't paid
you know from products coming in
you were shut down in march for two
weeks is that correct well uh
that is correct we they asked us to shut
down uh for two weeks
and we were able to stay open for
carryouts
uh we chose just to ride out to two
weeks because it you know as far as we
knew it two weeks later with the open
carryout is you know what we're not a
fast food uh
place where it was set up for
full-service dining in in
anybody that's in this industry
understands it doing high volume
carryout in a place like owls is very
very difficult it's very
expensive it's very labor intense so we
chose it to ride out to two weeks but
after the two weeks
we saw that it was going to keep going
so we we reopened
just to carry out at that time okay and
then how long did you do takeout only
we did take out uh i believe we
i believe it went into some somewhere in
june
they allowed us to do outdoor seating so
we did take out until then
um and the only reason we survived
through the takeoff because we we
couldn't i mean it's
you know it's like i said it's labor
intensive to do takeout i almost need 21
employees just to
you know to produce the product to get
it out um which is
is you know very expensive but you know
the the ppp
was enough to help us get through until
uh
we're finally allowed to open up doors
and do outdoor dining and then at that
point we put a tent in our parking lot
right and you talked about ppp so you
you were able to get one of those
federal loans which you don't have to
pay back correct you were able to get
some money from the government to help
sustain your operation for a couple of
months that is correct
and what about your employees at the
point we closed we had 70 employees
now we're down to about 33 employees i
didn't let anybody go
once we reopened i brought them all back
and the ones that didn't come back chose
not to uh you know they want somewhere
else you talked about takeout you said
you stayed alive for for those two
months
what percentage would you say you you
made doing take
out without any indoor dining about 35
so you lost that much money which of
what you normally do 65 yeah we lost or
whatever it comes out to yeah
wow and then so then you go when you're
allowed to do the outdoor dining
so does did the money come in more once
you started that
so it did what happened we got up to
about 65 percent
during the outdoor dining uh we're we're
fortunate enough to have a patio which
we have uh nine tables and then in the
tent
we're able to put 17 tables so that was
uh
uh that comes out to what 26 tables that
we added
so you know as long as the weather was
uh
you know favorable we were able to uh
you know
we're staying about we got up to about
65
of our sales at one time i was uh to we
were doing and uh
and then of course when we were you know
we were instructed to
close up the outdoor seating we lost
those 26 tables which
which really hurts all right now in
through any of this
have you had any indoor dining uh
yes i think what was right around july
first we were allowed to see 25 percent
yeah okay and that continued until the
new order
that was issued that is correct in your
state and so
the order came in for you to shut down
the indoor dining and you did what
uh well we've known it we ignored it
so we we chose to just stay open and you
know we got together out here
in this area most of us did we did a
skype interview with an attorney
and i think there's about 80 of us on
that skype and uh
in in most of us sent him a retainer so
we had council
and i i would say that most of the
people in this area are still open
um because again they have no choice are
you talking about restaurant owners like
yourself the 80
are you talking about business owners
like yourself in in your area and carol
stream
i am i'm saying yeah not just carol
stream but in the in the adjoining
uh villages we call them villages out
here uh
county yeah this is quite a few that are
still open
um maybe less vocal than i might be but
um you know we're just uh we're trying
to survive
out here i've got you know like i said
just under 35 employees and with
families and
i've got seven single moms that have
nothing else to do
the business getting the most attention
lately even getting notoriety on
saturday night live
is max public house on staten island in
new york city
it defied orders to end indoor dining
and then
sheriffs came in seemed like a whole lot
of them
co-owner danny presti who's been fined
and had his liquor license stripped was
arrested telling fox's tucker carlson
just wanted to take me out
seemed a whole big ordeal he was
arrested again
days later accused of hitting and
injuring a law enforcement officer with
his car
nothing like that has happened at mike's
village tavern and grill in illinois
they don't want boarded up buildings in
there in their villages out here they
don't want people closing down and
employees on the street uh and what not
so
um they they're not you know as much as
we we've had the health department come
by
we've had phone calls from local
government and they're concerned
but we haven't gotten to the point where
they're you know this we have a sheriff
showing up at the door and uh i don't
believe the local police sheriff whoever
really want to do that anyways so you
haven't even gotten a fine
no fines no how far outside chicago are
you
uh about 25 30 miles outside of chicago
but if you so if you were in the city
you would be in trouble
i would say if we're in the city we're
under the control of mere
light foot then we would be in in more
trouble yes
so when you were complying with the
restrictions before this
what did you do what kinds of things did
you do to comply how much money did you
have to spend
oh thousands and thousands of dollars i
mean
we took it to the you know extreme level
we've you know we've had
several sanitizing stations in here
we've got thousands of dollars in
plexiglas
you know we've x out every other table
so there's a six foot
distance between tables out here we um
put a
state-of-the-art air purification system
in that that uh
cleans the air as it goes and you know
people understand this is
we have an open kitchen here we have an
exhaust system our exhaust system
is pulling all the air out of this out
of this restaurant
constantly so it's being replaced with
purified
air i'm sure it's cleaner to eat in this
restaurant than it is most homes
it is we're wiping everything down as
they come in we've got
every employee's wearing masks we have a
sign in the front that
uh don't answer without a mask on um you
know
we wet all the economies and tables down
after someone gets up
someone uses a salt check it goes to one
area where it's sanitized and then goes
to the next area
where you can use it um so we've taken
every
uh step that we can and every protocol
that's out there
to make sure that people walk in here
are safe
and there's no evidence that that i have
seen
that says that restaurants are spreaders
is in and when they close us down three
weeks ago
for access to close down there was seven
and then in the nine months that we were
going through this culvert there was
seven people documented and i don't know
how they
even found that out that were they
caught
covert in restaurants seven people and
they're going to shut down the whole
state
at least the whole county in michigan
governor gretchen whitmer a democrat
while extending her restrictions another
12 days banning indoor dining
said adults testing positive for covet
are about twice as likely to have dined
at a restaurant
compared to those testing negative our
progress
is fragile and we cannot let up yet
research being reviewed published in the
journal nature showed
the majority of coronavirus spread takes
place in restaurants gyms hotels and
religious organizations like churches in
a study of major urban areas
mike coughlin remains unconvinced well
according to an article it just came out
a couple days ago from the cdc
uh it even says in there the restaurant
is not it's not a high spreader
and and just we had the uh admiral on
yesterday which is part of the
uh trump uh culver team saying that
there's there's no science of outdoor
spreading and then
they try to minimize what you can
indoors and that's what we've been doing
we've been minimizing what's indoors
what about contact tracing i mean you're
staying open through all of this
what happens if somebody says hey mike i
got sick in your restaurant
well a lot of people have have half
through the months i mean i mean
i'm not going to say that you know we're
not denying culverts out there
you know my best friend was a
restaurateur almost died he wasn't he
was under ventilator for forever but
um you know that do you think i don't
know can you hide from a
from a um you know a a virus like this i
never heard of hiding from viruses
unless you just walked up in your house
and
never go out i mean i i think it gets
out there
no matter what you do i think you just
need to have precautions to protect the
weak and the elderly
but uh you know every time we had an
employee
that uh that had symptoms or might have
gotten sick you know
14 days don't come back you know get
tested
whatever we're doing everything we
possibly can we had to close a couple
times just because
we had some staff out there were sick
and we didn't want to take a chance
there's talk of another round of
financial aid
uh do you want more federal help how do
you stand well
let me look well i only just say that
everybody
that i know in this industry in in in
small business in general because let's
face it it's
small business is going to hurt he's
going to need it i mean i'm not going to
be able to survive
um another couple months at
25 of my business or whatever it might
be
and um and you know it's it's just
because we're open doesn't mean
that people are flocking out to you
because there's a lot of scared people
out there
i mean it's half the country will come
out half the country won't
um so yeah is it dependent if it
if the governor says we can't open until
january
february and then we have to stay at 25
you know none of us will survive without
without uh any more help so congress
needs to step
up and do the right thing i imagine you
are rooting for the vaccine as hard as
anybody
hey i'm running for whatever makes
people feel safe
and want to go back out you know two
fridays ago
the governor sent out a it's an amber a
type of alert on all of our phones
telling people to stay put staying home
don't go out don't eat with your family
whatever it was
and that's getting the hell out of
everybody it really did we saw we saw a
decline in uh
and people coming out at that point well
we uh we hope you can uh can continue to
survive i know a lot of restaurants have
not
and and and mike we really appreciate
your time and thanks for joining us
well thanks for having me mike coughlin
village tavern and grill and carol
stream illinois take care
new from the fox news podcast network my
name is kennedy and welcome to
my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome
it's kennedy saves the world subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
abby hornacek
what's on your mind we made it
congratulations
it's officially the holiday season and
it's not breaking news that this year
is going to look different than what
we're used to but god has a plan for
everything
right so if we look at it that way we're
able to ask the question
what can bring us comfort in this
unpredictability of life during the
storm of coven 19.
look i don't have all the answers but in
my opinion
a simple way to look at that question is
to find something we can root ourselves
in that's predictable and what is more
predictable during the holiday season
than traditions the nice thing about
traditions
is they don't change and in a world that
has changed a lot
in 2020 and continues to do so we should
strive to find
solace in the things that have been
resilient through the test of time
like checking the sky for santa claus
with your little ones
or finding the perfect branch to hang
that special ornament on
or gathering around with your favorite
people to light your menorah
things that have unmeasurable value and
touch our hearts like snow on christmas
morning
it is so easy to get lost in the chaos
but traditions ground us
when you think about the germans way
back in the day introducing the first
christmas tree to america
or martin luther walking home one night
and seeing the stars shine
on the evergreen trees sparking that
idea for adorning our trees with
christmas lights
those are things that were given to us
long before our time
and remind us to return to the simple
things that bring us happiness
coven 19 may be unpredictable but
traditions are like comfort food for the
soul
so from our family here at fox to yours
have a
merry holiday season and i hope you find
joy and peace
and the little moments that connect us
all
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at fox
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
it's the perino and stirewalt i'll tell
you what podcast
dana perino of the five and fox news
political editor chris stirewall dissect
the ins and outs of national politics
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes